[APPLAUSE]
TORRENCE BOONE: So thank you
for taking the time to join us,
and why don't we dive in?
You've written an
extraordinary book,
one that is both incredibly
personal, but at the same time
incredibly important in
terms of the gay rights
movement, human
rights in general,
diversity, all of
those dimensions.
As a kicking off point,
why did you write it?
JOHN BROWNE: Well, good morning.
I wrote it because someone
eventually persuaded me
by total persistence
that I should write it.
But I was thinking
about the book,
I thought it was
important to write
a book which did the
following things.
First, it stopped anyone getting
in the same mess as I got into.
It would be a
tragedy, in my view,
if someone repeated the
mistakes that I'd made.
Secondly, to give people
a sense that there
are plenty of role models
out there, in business,
in corporate life, where they
could see some of themselves,
not all of themselves,
but role models
tend to give people confidence
to be themselves and for good
and for bad.
Thirdly, I wrote it
to write a letter
to all the straight
people in the world.
I wanted to write a
letter which said,
you've really got
to think about this.
And the straight people are
very important, the allies are
critical, because if we want
to make it possible for people
to be themselves in corporate
life, to be authentic,
then all the help comes
from straight people,
and that is most of the
leaders in business.
The fourth reason I wrote it
was a very simple observation.
I kept looking around for
role models, and I said,
there's got to be a
gay CEO somewhere.
And so I looked at
the S&P 500, and I
saw there were no out gay CEOs.
So I then looked at
the rest of the list,
and when I wrote the book,
you had to go down to S&P 723
before you found an out gay CEO.
And I said, that's odd.
It's statistically improbable--
[LAUGHTER]
And I think that something's
wrong-- either people are
in the closet, or gay people
have been discriminated
against, or maybe gay
people have just opted out.
They haven't got
into the business
of wanting to go to
the top of a company.
And there were no role models.
So I said, we got to
write it, and let's see
what happens after
I've written it.
TORRENCE BOONE: Fantastic.
So take us back to May of
2007, which is in many ways
the kicking off
point of the book,
and that was the time when
the press made it explicit
that you are gay.
You were outed in a
very dramatic way.
Tell us about what was going
through your head, your heart,
during that time, and what
you describe as being somewhat
eaten alive by the media
vultures of the time.
Just take us back then.
JOHN BROWNE: Well,
the story starts
before May 1, 2007, which
was Labor Day-- I thought
I had a very interesting
and important moment to do
something important-- but
we'll come back to that.
Because I'd become a figure
of a lot of public interest
during my time as
running BP-- BP
came from a very small company
to a very large company--
and it tried to do all sorts
of things rather differently.
And during that time, I
was always in the closet.
Actually I'd been in the closet
since I grew up in the '60s.
In the '60s, being
gay was effectively
a recipe for being
blackmailed or bullied,
because in most parts of
the world, including the UK,
it was illegal for people to
undertake a homosexual act.
So I stayed in the closet.
My late mother, who was
an Auschwitz survivor
always said to me, two rules
of life will preserve you.
Number one, never
tell anyone a secret,
because it's no longer a secret.
And number two, never be a
visible member of a minority,
because when the going gets
tough minorities always hurt,
and from her point of view
that was exactly correct.
So this was drilled into me,
so I built a couple of lives.
I felt like James Bond.
[LAUGHTER]
I had a life which had
no sexuality in it,
and I had a gay life, and
I kept these very separate.
And as I got more
and more well known,
it was more and more difficult
to keep the two lives separate,
and actually to have a gay life.
So I decided to reduce
risk, and by reducing risk,
I increased risk gigantically.
I said the only way
I can meet someone
is through an escort
website, which I did.
And I built a relationship with
a guy who I met, it fell apart,
and I thought nothing of it.
And at the beginning of
2007, I got a phone call
from a well-known
newspaper, "Mail on Sunday,"
"The Daily Mail," which
said that they cover
this sort of thing,
and which said
we've bought a story from
your former boyfriend
about your entire life, and
we have the following 29 or 39
questions we'd like you to
answer-- Friday evening,
published on Sunday--
a classic trick.
So I decided that I'd
say, this is my life.
Why should someone
advertise my privacy?
So I stopped the
story being published
by taking out what's called
a super injunction with lots
of lawyers and all sorts
of things like that.
And in so doing, I
made a fatal error.
Because I couldn't bring
myself to say where we'd met,
I lied on where we met, and I
corrected it a few days later,
but it was a very bad thing.
So this lawsuit carried
on, carried on, carried on.
I couldn't tell anyone about it.
It would be Contempt of Court
if I did, and lo and behold
eventually I lost
my last appeal,
and I was told that the story
would come out on May 1.
So about that time I'd been
almost preparing myself
in some ways, but you can't
really prepare yourself,
to say that my life was
really about to change,
involuntary change, and so
everything would change.
So I resolved that I
would resign from BP,
because it was
embarrassing for BP,
and the board is
terribly conservative.
And so on May 1, I had a letter
delivered to my chairman,
resigning, and I walked out
of the front door of BP.
I walked out of BP
for the last time
into a huge throng of press.
And when it was all over the
world, and for three days
I was hounded by paparazzi
on motorbikes and long lenses
and stuff like that.
So eventually that all
stopped, and I went away,
and I thought about
my life and I said,
absolutely everything has
to change, which it did.
So I stopped doing everything
I was doing, and said,
let's start again.
And one of my wise
friends said, that'll
be fine because all this
nonsense with the press,
it is the dogs bark
and the caravan
moves on, so you're no longer
a story, which was true.
TORRENCE BOONE: So
one of the things
that you do, I think,
incredibly well in the book
is to communicate that
sense of fear and anxiety
as you were grappling
with all of these issues,
and I think it's an
interesting perspective
to share with the group the kind
of mental process happening,
because you were
not actually even
truthful to your
lawyer to some extent.
JOHN BROWNE: Correct.
TORRENCE BOONE: Correct?
Was there anyone who knew?
Was anyone looped into what
you were thinking, feeling?
JOHN BROWNE: Not really, no.
I kept it all to myself.
In my head, I'd built a
whole structure of fears.
Fears that if I
came out, I wouldn't
be taken as seriously
as if I didn't come out.
Fears that I'd lose my friends.
They'd cross the street
when I walked past them.
Fears that people would
not do business with me,
that clients, suppliers, will
think I was rather trivial.
And since I was in a very
geopolitical business,
that all the heads of state
would say, you disgust me,
we don't want you, and
everything would fall apart.
So I'd convinced myself
about this, and as a result,
I protected the secret according
to my mother's instruction,
tell nobody.
So I did that, and of course,
when you debate with yourself
with nobody else, you
rarely get the right answer.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: Because
you're always right.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: And so it's
difficult to get out
of this box of fears.
And of course when it happened,
I realized that all of these
were sheer and utter nonsense.
It wasn't true that
I lost my friends.
If anything, I made more.
I didn't lose my
business contacts.
They stayed the same.
I was thinking to myself maybe
after I publish this book,
or after I came out, I would
be made persona non grata
in some countries
in the world where
it's illegal to
promote homosexuality.
Not at all.
So nothing changed, except I
changed a lot, because I now
could be more of
myself, and I was better
at connecting with
people than I used to be.
One of my bosses from the
early days has a great wife.
When we had dinner in
San Francisco recently,
she said to me,
she said, I always
knew there was
something up with you
because you defined
the word reserved,
even for an Englishman.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: There was something
really deeply reserved,
and that was right.
TORRENCE BOONE: And you talk
a lot about that as well,
the liberating
notion of coming out,
the burden of being
in the closet.
So related, and your mother was
incredibly important to you.
She was not with you during
the unfolding of a lot of this,
but had clearly played
an important part
as all mothers do, but she was
also your surrogate partner
as well in that
she lived with you,
you went to a lot of events and
those sorts of things with her.
What advise do you think
she would have given you?
Or how would she reflect
on this whole thing?
JOHN BROWNE: It's
impossible to say
because this is, all
other things being equal,
a hypothetical question.
But people rarely
change deeply held views
which form part of their
character, where they've
come through something as
terrifying as the Holocaust.
So I doubt very much whether
she changed her view that people
aren't reliable with
secrets, you don't tell them,
and just don't get in
the way of the majority
when something goes wrong,
because, in the words of one
of my other friends,
advances with minorities
always require
constant vigilance.
It is not something you
can simply say, it's done.
It's not done, and
she would say that.
TORRENCE BOONE: But
also be happy, proud,
that you've made it
to the other side.
JOHN BROWNE: As a pragmatist, as
a practical person, of course.
Of course, of course.
TORRENCE BOONE:
So I actually want
to go back to something
that you mentioned earlier,
the notion of being a
spy, of a spy in training.
There's a great quote
from the book where
you say, "the longer I kept up
my charade, the more successful
I became.
At times I found my
double life thrilling,
and I thought
conducting it somehow
improved my skill
at sensing danger,
as if I were a spy in training.
I persuaded myself that this
was the right way to live."
So how do you reflect on
this observation today?
What lessons do you think it
provides gay professionals who
are going through the
same types of issues?
JOHN BROWNE: Well first,
I hope no one gets
into the same position of
having two lives like this.
I hope that they can
bring them together
because there's
such a hidden cost.
But I think one of
the things it does
is when you've got two lives,
you get very, flexible,
you get very attuned at
reading danger and reading
people very quickly.
It's a skill which comes
just by observation
of what they do after
you've met them,
and then you go back
and correlate it
to the first impression,
and you build this database
because it's a matter
of survival as opposed
to a matter of luxury
or academic interest.
So it teaches you
this, and it teaches
you to be much more accurate
about sizing people up.
You get it wrong sometimes,
but it does do that.
Now whether that is
a skill-- I'm always
very reluctant to say
that there are skills that
go with sectors--
it may or may not
be a skill that
LGBT people have,
but it's a skill that people
who are threatened certainly
develop, certainly develop.
TORRENCE BOONE: Well,
and also a skill
that can be very useful in
the context of business.
JOHN BROWNE: It can be.
TORRENCE BOONE: And you even
make reference to that--
and many of the people
you interview-- the book
is wonderful in that it
provides a pretty broad sweep
of industries, business,
sports, law, and a number
of very successful people, some
of whom are still in the closet
despite the current context.
JOHN BROWNE: Yes.
They masquerade with
false names in the book.
There aren't that many of those.
TORRENCE BOONE: But they talk
about some of the advantages
actually of having to
negotiate this double life
and the potential
impact that it has
on their success
in the workplace.
JOHN BROWNE: Yes, they all
would admit that they are not
as engaged in what they're doing
as they might have been had
they been able to be
themselves at work.
And I think that's the
big point, the business
point about why coming
out is good for business.
Engaged teams always
perform better.
There are tons of
studies which show that,
and companies with engaged teams
have a premium out performance,
compared with the average.
It's enormous.
It's 2% a year over 20
years for the companies
that genuinely
have engaged teams.
And LGBT people feeling safe,
feeling safe to come out
and being part of a company
in its fullest sense,
are a leading
indicator, a litmus test
of how people are
engaged in the company.
TORRENCE BOONE: And clearly
an important part of that
is mentorship and role models,
which you led off with.
And it was curious you share a
story about Frank Rickwood, who
was your boss here
in New York, and that
was a pivotal point
in your career.
This is an also closeted
gay professional,
and again it's always hard
to live in hypotheticals,
but I think that one of the
things gay professionals, those
out and in the
closet, grapple with
is some sense of
connectivity to people
who are going through
the same thing.
If you both had known
that you were gay,
or if you project
to the challenges
that people in a similar
situation confront today,
how do you think that
dialogue would unfold?
What are the
implications for actually
having some sense of
a mentor or role model
in your professional life?
JOHN BROWNE: Role
models are crucial.
When I was working
for Frank Rickwood,
the last thing I would
have ever dreamt of doing
would be to actually
make a connection.
There was a gap of seniority.
Well, there was the gap
of fear that maybe I'd
got it a bit wrong.
I wasn't quite sure.
What would happen
to this information?
But today, things are
different in some environments,
but role models
are most important
because part of what they
provide other people is
confidence that it's OK to be
out, that it's good to be out,
that it doesn't get in the way
of promotion, that people do
have a better life.
And you can see it rather
than just read about it.
You can actually see it
through some real person.
That's important.
That's why I believe
role models are essential
and why so much of the book
talks about role models.
When I was writing the book,
halfway through the book,
I thought we might have
got to the point of being,
if you will, post-gay, that
the book might no longer be
relevant.
And then I started meeting
a lot of professionals
to be interviewed for the
book, between 25 and 35,
and I was struck by the
number of those people who
did not want to
come out at work.
They really believe
that it would
be a singular damaging event.
It would prevent them
from being promoted.
It would make them exposed
to potential bullying.
It would make them weak.
And therefore, they
absolutely would not do it,
and that's why there were
a lot of people who gave us
interviews on the understanding
of confidentiality,
and some were very extreme.
When we read back
some interviews,
we read back an interview
to a man who we identified
as a banker in London, and
he said, you can't say that.
People may know who I am.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's extreme, but it's
part of a set of fears.
TORRENCE BOONE: Yes.
So after you came out, which
was this extraordinary event,
you received
thousands of letters.
Can you share with
us just reflections
on those letters, things that
were surprising, inspirational.
JOHN BROWNE: A
lots of the letters
came from straight
people who had
got into a mess
with relationships,
and they'd been exposed.
They said to me this
is exactly the same.
You just change he
to she, she to he,
and the same
situations occurred,
but we didn't get this
amount of press coverage
because we're straight
and you're gay.
And that was a very
important factor at the time.
I have a feeling
it's still a factor.
They wanted to share with
me their experiences,
and to a person to share
with me the experience
that after a period of time it
all got better, that there was
something really
to look forward to.
I had a lot of
people write to me
who I'd been in business
with, who wanted to assure me
that they want to carry on,
and they thought this was great
and I'd have a good and full
life, including thousands
and thousands of people
who worked in BP.
In fact, I think over
10,000 instant emails,
and in those days emails
were a little bit more
clumsy than they are today.
And then there were
a very few people
who talked to me
in their letters
about the tragedy that had
befallen them as they came out.
People had been to jail
before the law changed, people
whose lives have been
destroyed by other people,
and it reminded me that not
everything works out well
under any circumstances
for anything.
While we should aspire
to make coming out
a really great
event for everybody,
it may not be for
everybody, and so it
is an individual decision.
But on balance, it's one
people should really do,
because the risk reward
is in favor of coming out.
TORRENCE BOONE: Yes, yes.
So we're going to open
it up to the audience
in just a few minutes.
So if you guys have questions
and want to move to the mics,
feel free to do that.
Before we open it up, I
wanted to follow on that.
You met your partner actually
shortly after this incident.
Can you tell us
about that process?
And now you're in a committed
relationship, right?
JOHN BROWNE: It's
absolutely extraordinary.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: So while
everything changed,
and I changed my
job, changed all
of the activities I was doing,
one thing that didn't change
was the secrecy of my private
address for security reasons.
So all the mail came
to my business address,
and except for one letter
arrived at my private address
from someone who said, I've
read everything about you.
I'm so sorry this all happened.
It's really unfair, and we
hope that it gets better
in the future.
Perhaps you'd like to
have a drink with me.
[LAUGHTER]
So I thought, so first, how
did this person get my address
because nobody had my address.
So I didn't know.
So then I said, absolutely,
I'll have a drink with you,
and I postponed it
three times because I
was busy doing things.
The fourth time,
amazingly, he said fine.
We had a drink, and we
got to know each other,
and one thing led
to another and we've
been together for
over seven years now.
Now how'd he get the address?
That was the interesting thing.
[LAUGHTER]
So he used to be a
banker, incidentally.
He decided against
banking, and has now
gone into the-- he was
very, very successful--
gone into the restaurant
business instead.
He likes being attached
to things with his hands.
So he looked at photographs
in the newspapers,
and it said that I
lived in Chelsea,
and there was a photograph
outside my apartment building.
The numbers were blurred
out for security reasons.
Anyway he said, I
know exactly where
this building is,
I've walked past it.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: So he then
walked past it again,
and he said, since the
doorbells have no names on,
just numbers, he said, why
not just write a letter
and if he's not there, it'll be
thrown away or returned to me.
And so that's how it
happened, a little piece
of investigative activity.
TORRENCE BOONE: Right.
Excellent, excellent.
Yes, we have a question, please.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
thank you for being here,
and for writing this book.
It's a really
important touch point
and thing to
understand about what
it means to bring your true
self and your authentic self
to your work, so
thank you for that.
I'm curious, at a
place like Google,
I see people around me
coming out every day.
And it's not that
they're in the closet,
it's just that as you meet
new people in business
and they ask you and get to
know you and they ask you
about your life, you're
constantly coming out.
And Google is,
hopefully, one of those
places where it's easier to
constantly be coming out,
but I could see really
traditional corporate type
jobs, finance, banking,
being in the law field,
as more difficult places to
be constantly coming out,
and maybe that's something that
keeps people in that closet.
What kind of advice
would you have
to people that are
faced with that
and need to maybe figure out
a way to get over that hump
and be their authentic self,
no matter how, to your point,
conservative the
environment might be.
JOHN BROWNE: Well,
I think if people
feel unsafe about coming out,
they're not going to come out.
And it's wrong to push them
in the face of what they
may see as something
really dangerous to them.
The right way to
answer this question
is to go back and say, why
is it difficult to come out
in some companies?
And it has to start at the top.
It's the tone set by the
leader and the follow
up from the tone, the
measurement of the impact
of the signal she or he is
giving, the time people attend
to working on
inclusion of all sorts,
especially LBGT
which is, I think,
one of the more
difficult and the leading
indicator of getting
inclusion right.
And identifying role
models on the way,
to make it possible for
you to identify better.
If the environment
is very hostile,
there is no choice
but to say, I'm either
going to be in
the closet, or I'm
going to find
somewhere else to work.
And I think people do
go and find other places
to work, when they find
themselves unsettled
and in an area where they
see no solution but to not
be themselves.
Because everybody really
does want to be themselves,
but they want to be themselves
and part of a society, not
separate and an odd
thing in society.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So another question
relating to the idea of tone
that you mentioned, a pretty
common example of someone who
fits in this category would
be Tim Cook, the CEO of Apple.
And he, in a lot of
situations has indirectly
acknowledged his sexuality.
He showed up at the Pride
March with Apple employees,
but on some level, he's
still very unwilling
to talk about it.
It's in all of his
interview notes
that it's not to be discussed.
So, on one hand, what do you
think that says about the tone
he's setting for the culture
at a place like Apple,
and also for the
industry at large,
just in terms of
acknowledging it on some level
but not really putting it
on the table for discussion.
JOHN BROWNE: I
don't know Mr. Cook.
I knew his predecessor,
but I don't know Mr. Cook.
So forgive me.
I'm not going to comment on
him, but what I might comment on
is leaders generally.
It's possibly true that
for most people, coming out
is a matter of personal choice.
The sadness which
I feel about myself
is that when you're a leader,
there isn't that choice.
You've got to demonstrate
that you're authentic.
You have to come out.
Otherwise why
would anybody else?
They feel it's not
quite on the agenda,
so I think you
have to demonstrate
by being authentic yourself.
That is very important.
I think the second
thing is that people
have to come out several times.
Obviously when
you're changing jobs,
people discover your
sexuality again and again,
or you might tell them as you
go from one company to the next.
When people become
CEOs-- I've observed
in the limited number of cases
where people have come out--
they have to be
comfortable in their job
that things are going
OK, and then they'll
come out again in
the position of CEO.
It's not an immediate reaction.
So it's a progress of
coming out, but in the end
it's really important
to have the biggest role
models available.
I'm the most senior
business person ever
to be identified
as gay, I believe,
and this is not a
description I want
to have for very much longer.
I'd much prefer someone who's
running a big company today
to be out and be
a big role model.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And would you also
add that same sort
of sense of
obligation and setting
the tone applies for people
in the political world?
JOHN BROWNE: Yes.
Politicians are doing OK.
More and more politicians
are coming out.
The cynic would say
it's dangerous for them
not to, because their
authenticity would
be questioned, they'll be
pilloried in the press,
but people feel comfortable
coming out today,
and voters seem to be
accepting of sexuality as a non
issue in many, many parts
of Europe and the USA.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
TORRENCE BOONE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So Google is one
of these young, progressive
companies.
We have rainbow flags everywhere
from the sign on our building
to our Olympic doodles to hidden
in our spreadsheet application,
and we participate
in the parade.
We have clubs, t-shirts.
Does that mean, are we good?
Do we just wait for the rest
of the world to catch up?
It feels on some level
like there's so much more
that we could be
doing to advance
the normalization of
people of all identities
and orientations.
JOHN BROWNE: There
have to be many things.
First, being there,
and demonstrating
that you run a company which
has no barriers to inclusion.
So people can be themselves
is an important point.
It seems to me just being there
is important, but there's more.
People can talk about what it's
like to be in an environment
where you can be
yourself without fear.
You can talk to suppliers.
Suppliers need to
have the same value
set, the same
practices as Google.
Google can influence them.
Google can influence by
economic nudging countries
that it works in.
It's not always
successful, but I always
found that CEOs were
given a big list of
to do's, like clean up the
environment, fix human rights,
make sure that
everyone gets a job,
increase growth and increase
value, do all of the above
simultaneously.
But actually, you do
bits at different times,
and when you meet people
who run countries or are
influential in a country,
you can say, well of course,
I'm putting a gay leader here.
They're very good, and
I want you to know that,
and if I can't, then
I might not be here.
So a little push here and there
from substantial corporations
is very powerful because
they can't be ignored.
Governments, of course,
can sanction and do
things they rarely
do, but corporations
can do bit by bit pushing.
AUDIENCE: It
resonated for me when
you were speaking before
about the experience of being
in the closet and that
teaches you certain things,
in terms of being circumspect
and gauging situations, just
being trained to do that
as part of your normal life
and how that can be
advantageous in business.
Sometimes I say to
myself, hey Chris,
you don't have to be that
way anymore in business.
I wonder, have you had
any similar experiences,
where you had ways of being
which you learned where you
realized for yourself this
is actually disadvantageous
now in business?
JOHN BROWNE: Good question.
With no real clear
answer, I believe
what I do is
discipline myself not
to behave in a way which
dissembles about me.
I will not, in all cases, use it
as the opening line and neither
would anybody.
But when someone says,
do you have a wife?
I say no, I have a male partner.
I'm clear about it.
I don't avoid
questions, and that
is something which is
very important to me.
I still read people.
I still think about what is
the right way to negotiate.
I still try and never give any
signal about what I'm thinking.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: It's a
skill in negotiation.
TORRENCE BOONE: And poker.
[LAUGHTER]
So I do all of those things,
because they're good things,
but what I don't do is
dissemble about myself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TORRENCE BOONE: Yes, Lisa.
AUDIENCE: Hi, and
I want to thank
you so much for being here.
This is such an
interesting discussion.
Recently during Pride Week,
Kim Stolz came to speak here,
and she got a question
about being a out queer
woman in the corporate world.
She is most famously a former
contestant on "America's Next
Top Model," less
famously a VP of Equity
of Derivatives Trading
at Credit Suisse.
And her argument is that
actually being out and queer
in finance had actually
only benefited her
because at this point so
many large corporations are
so desperate for
diversity, particularly
the financial
sphere, that she is
a very valued member of her
team and an interesting bastion
and symbol of a new
age of business.
I'm just wondering what your
reaction is to that because I
feel like a lot
of this discussion
is about the more negative
side of coming out,
the fact that it's
a personal decision,
and I was interested to hear
from her that she thought
it was only positive
and the future is going
to move towards it actually
being a point of empowerment
for some employees.
JOHN BROWNE: If I've said
this is all negative,
don't believe me.
I believe it's a very
important and powerful thing
to come out because you're just
going to be a better person.
You're going to be
more relaxed, you're
going to use your mind and your
skill on what you're doing,
rather than half of it figuring
out how not to be who you are,
which is complicated.
With inclusion comes a very high
standard of merit, I believe.
If that doesn't work,
then the whole idea
of including people on an
equal basis begins to corrode.
I want to make sure, at
least from my point of view,
that people get jobs
because they're qualified
to do that as I'm sure,
incidentally, she is,
but It's not about
their sexuality.
We don't have quotas for
sexuality, I don't believe,
and neither should we.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I was just interested to
hear your reaction because I
myself had a somewhat
similar reaction.
I don't love thinking of myself
as a diversity hire, someone
who's filling a box,
but at the same time,
I was like, you know what,
take what you can get.
It's kind of empowering
in a strange way.
JOHN BROWNE: Well,
it's true, but I
would say, but remember
the consequences
of taking what you can get.
AUDIENCE: Very true.
Thank you.
TORRENCE BOONE: And that's
actually a great segue.
Part of the title of your
book is why coming out
is good for business.
You devote a chapter
to that question.
Obviously, there are
themes throughout the book.
Give us the synopsis
of your thinking
on why it is good for business.
JOHN BROWNE: First,
when businesses
do the right thing, usually
they're pretty good businesses.
So when they have
values that make sense,
chances are they've got a
lot of other things going
for them that give them a
greater chance of success.
Secondly, engaged staff,
engaged teams, are better teams.
They're not wandering
around saying,
I wish I ought to think
about something else,
I've got to think about myself.
I'm going to be
engaged with the team,
and engagement takes many forms.
When you work with
people, you do
have to know a little
bit about them.
We are not machines.
At least I don't think
we are machines yet.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
We're working on that actually
here at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN BROWNE: Well,
I'll just check.
That's why I thought I'd ask it.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: So
there is an empathy,
which has to be built up
in a high performance team,
and by being out, you
can be more engaged.
Thirdly, the numbers show it.
I'm very struck by
all these studies
which show hugely different
returns, much better returns,
when you have engaged staff.
That of course, covers
everything, from gender,
race, all sorts of things.
But actually LGBT is one
of those litmus tests
which says, if you get
that right, chances
are a lot of things are
going to fall in place,
if you really work on this
particular more complex area.
TORRENCE BOONE:
Yeah, well there's
that great example in the book
where there's a career fair.
JOHN BROWNE: Career fair.
TORRENCE BOONE: And it's
an LGBT career fair.
And there are all of these Asian
women coming up and getting
information on the actual
environment or whatever,
and the recruiters
were just baffled,
because they were like, all
of these people cannot be gay.
[LAUGHING]
It's statistically
impossible, and it turned out
that they were interested
in this company-- I
forget the company-- but
they were interested in it
because they said,
if you figured out
how to deal with LGBT
issues, then in terms
of any other diversity
metric, be it race or gender,
you absolutely are
on the cutting edge.
So I thought that was a pretty
interesting observation.
JOHN BROWNE: It's one which
I believe holds water, too.
When you have to think about
inclusion as something which
is on everybody's
agenda, you change
the way a firm is
lead and managed.
I've lead lots of teams,
and when you say to a team,
well, we're going to
do something, something
new and more, most
managers come back to you
and say, now you've given me
88 things to do, the 89th,
where does that go?
What do you do with it?
And here's where you
need to work hard.
You need to create the
time and space for people
to work on the
area of inclusion,
especially with LGBT activity.
And I always say to
people, most CEOs
say that people are the
most important assets
in the company, and
if that's the case,
then they should be spending
their most important time
on people, which would
normally mean, let's say,
half their time on people.
Most people don't do that.
Maybe they should,
and that would
make things very much better.
TORRENCE BOONE:
Yeah, and I think
there's an amazing insight
for me from the book--
we talk a lot about
diversity-- we do that
a lot here at Google-- but you
make the very clear distinction
between diversity and inclusion.
So you can have an amazing
amount of diversity,
but if you don't have a dynamic
and a commitment to inclusion,
it's almost for naught.
JOHN BROWNE: That's right.
That's right.
The operative part is inclusion.
The outcome is diversity.
TORRENCE BOONE: So there is
a final question that I have,
but before I get to that,
we'll take another one
from the floor.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if
you can talk more
about coming out to your
family because I've actually
found coming out at
work the easiest part.
JOHN BROWNE: So I
failed to do it.
I tried, and I realized
that I was coming up
with my mother against these
key principles of a secret
is a secret you
keep to yourself,
don't become a part
of the minority.
She really didn't want to hear.
Did she know?
She was smart enough to
have figured it all out.
She must have done.
AUDIENCE: They always do that.
TORRENCE BOONE:
Mothers always know.
JOHN BROWNE: They always know.
[LAUGHTER]
And my father died when
I was really quite young,
so it was not a topic
we talked about.
Interestingly, I've met a few
but rather surprising parents
while I've been
talking about my book.
Only last week, I was in
Henley on Thames in the UK
at a book fair, a very
conservative, rather nice part
of the UK, and I had two set of
middle-aged couples come to me
and said, could you sign
this book to our son?
We'd like him to come out.
And I thought that was an
extraordinary reversal of role.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TORRENCE BOONE: That speaks to
the power of what you've done.
So you also do an amazing job
of framing all of the dynamics
around gay rights around
the world, from the US,
to Uganda, to Russia,
to all sorts of places
around the world,
and you provide
a really interesting and
provocative point of view
around the tension that
exists between the progressive
experience that we have
in a place like the US
and the subculture of
a place like Google,
compared to other places
in the world where
there's a lot more work to do.
What is your projection
for the future?
In general, my
take from the book
is that you're very
optimistic, but given
all of these
challenges that we have
around the world
and the vigilance
that we need to
hang on to, what's
your projection 10 years
out for gay rights?
How should we think about that?
What can we individually
do to continue the charge?
JOHN BROWNE: I'm
optimistic, even sometimes
in the face of data
which should make
me pessimistic in this area.
Half the nations where being
gay or promoting homosexuality,
doing a gay act is illegal,
were former members
of the British Empire.
I guess we exported
the laws, and we
failed to export the update.
TORRENCE BOONE: [LAUGHING]
JOHN BROWNE: So they're stuck
with these laws of the past,
and they're in
one category where
they can be worked
on bit by bit,
and many people are trying to
do that to change these laws.
There are others
where it is partly
an economic war on a
minority, partly it's
to gain popular
votes, and those areas
need economic pressure, slow
but gentle economic pressure.
It's not just business.
It's the World Bank.
It's IMF.
It's the lending arrangements.
It's all part of a
package of human rights,
and LGBT rights
are human rights.
They are, and they need
to be in the same category
as the general suite
of human rights.
So we should rely
on people and push
them to maintain vigilance,
to do something about it.
I suppose one of
the big problems
is-- and I've worked
in many countries--
where in a variety of
areas laws are in place,
and they're enforced
selectively.
This puts everybody on
edge, whether that's
on environmental matters,
financial matters, or LGBT.
And that is the most
dangerous position to be in.
No one is sure, in that
case, what is going on.
Or where the laws have been
in place and in abeyance,
and they suddenly come
back for enforcement
which is the case in one or
two parts of the Far East.
So pressure, I believe
things will change
as the community of nations gets
closer, people keep traveling,
ideas keep exchanging.
These things have a
habit of ironing out.
The problem is how long will
it take, and that I don't know.
TORRENCE BOONE: Please join me
in thanking Lord John Browne.
[APPLAUSE]